let's read this first story Minneapolis
City Council unanimously vote to abolish
its police it was unanimous
unanimous Wow dude these people have
lost their minds that's the blue vote
blue there was there been several
studies that have come out every there's
okay out of every single group polled
every every possible demographic college
degree no college degree dropouts 30
plus 45 65 whatever male-female black
white Mexican whatever they all said no
to defunding the police except one group
self-described liberals was the only
group according to you gov that said
they had a plurality saying to fund the
police with higher education right so no
the high reg even even higher education
said no oh yeah so people with people
with postgraduate degrees
said no I don't I don't know who these
people think they're pandering to who's
in control there then dude that's the
case this is this is the reality right
now and I've been saying it for a long
time and this is why I think we are on
the right side if the polls over and
over and over again say that nope no
don't define the police that they do it
anyway yeah clearly everything this is
insane like this it makes no sense
they're the the Democrats themselves
have tried to reject this Bernie Sanders
says no right they're still doing it yet
Biden's campaign is like the thing we
shouldn't do that the thing you know
it's a thing listen
Trump across the line first he squeezed
them he hammered them and he made them
desperate in their desperation they
turned took her people they didn't quite
understand yeah that's uh that's the
Batman so I don't really think Trump
crossed the line first I think Trump is
a symptom of everything was going on but
you had all this insanity and culture
which responded with you know resulted
in people saying they're gonna you know
a lot of people want to vote for Trump
for a few reasons one of which was
political correctness yeah and then the
left was insane they lost and they
didn't know why they lost in 2016
they're doing the same playbook so then
what do they do they start pandering to
these lunatics on Twitter
Twitter will ban a conservative what
they will let the far left go insane
Jack Dorsey himself will glorify
violence no repercussions
and then what happens is these people
see this stuff and they think this must
be real life must be you know the
funniest thing I heard was like a member
which a journalist said this but they're
like you'll often hear critics some
conservative and right-wing pundits say
that Twitter isn't real life what
they're really saying is certain voices
aren't allowed at the table what yep Oh
their argument is that Twitter allows
marginalized voices a chance to speak up
okay and those that argue it's not real
life are arguing that these marginalized
voices aren't actually of merit no it
means that there is a fringe group of
wackos who don't even represent those
marginalized groups convincing people
they do and convincing the entire City
Council to abolish its police department
so they say they're gonna replace it
with community lead public safety system
while NYC leaders push plan to cut one
billion dollars from the NYPD budget
well what is what is the regular NYPD
but I think it's like six billion six
billion I can be wrong and maybe maybe
thought maybe I'll bring it let's be a
little bit how they say the move comes
days after a veto-proof majority of the
council voted to disband the police
department after the country erupted in
protest and we know what we know all
about that thank you for informing us
the minneapolis vote was cast as new
york city council pushed to cut 1
billion dollars from the NYPD budget so
we have the twitter the tweet says from
the city of minneapolis the city council
unanimously approved a resolution today
declaring the intent to create a
transformative new model of cultivating
safety committing to a year-long process
of community engagement to guide the
prompt to guide the work so it looks
like we won't actually see any any
direct action for a year one thing we
will see though over this year I'm
willing to bet tomorrow all property
values in Minneapolis are down 40% some
ridiculous number Wow maybe even 80 or
90 maybe maybe even like just nothing
just gone it might even in know it might
it who's gonna pay to move in bad you
probably got places like Chaz happening
it's like they're just gonna move in and
be like you want us to pay no no no this
is our country now that's what they are
saying Chaz isn't there renouncing their
citizenship that are there really yes
yes what I've read it from multiple
sources and people down there and people
are there like this is art they're
holding guns they're like this is our
our country now we are no longer US
citizens and I'm like oh I didn't
believe it at first and then I saw it
from another source I'm like yeah you
know it's really funny is crazy did you
did you watch the Dave Chappelle thing
yet
I have you see how he called Don Lemon
would he call him us a dose of reality
or like but sarcastically yeah like that
piece of reality Don Lemon powerful
though Don Lemon is is an idiot but no
buts about anyway I bring that up
because CNN is trash yeah and uh Oliver
Darcy who is their media reporter wrote
the the weirdest story that ant armed
anti-fur isn't taking over a portion of
Seattle and then in the story he says
yes it's true and they've taken this
over he's smoked them yes right yeah but
here's the funny thing about it is that
when an tyfa is is invoked he and so
many others go head teeth was not even a
group and then as soon as it comes to
the question of whether or not anti felt
fellated groups are taking this place
over he goes well anti foot there other
groups are and it's like wait wait hold
on man
now you're of the of the of the
persuasion that antiva is an actual
group yeah now he's lying the best part
is though CNN had an on-the-ground
reporter right okay and the guys talking
and he's like it's very peaceful and
everything's fine
then someone jumps in front of the
camera and starts yelling trying to
block him cuz he's trying to shut down
the shot it's a he's got Skol enforce an
N calling him racist the guy moves and
then he says the most ridiculous thing
but you know he says something like the
people here are armed and so there is a
potential for bloodshed if the law if
law enforcement tries to remove them
it's like okay so which is it peaceful
you mean to tell me the peaceful
anti-fascists will shoot at cops
the peaceful law-abiding citizens now
I'm sorry dude CNN you can't have your
cake and eat it too so let me let me
show you this now I don't know so the
tweet says 18.6% of Minneapolis is total
real estate listings have popped up for
sale in just the last seven days and
two tweets one the unanimously passes
resolution to replace police department
with a community led Public Safety
system and then we have this which shows
you know that they did a search with the
past seven days 18 percent of the
listings popped up in the past week
here's what I did I pulled up Zillow I
chose a bunch of other cities Cincinnati
Boise Idaho
what else did I pick Topeka I didn't
really see a pattern
anything you could prove like in the
past seven days a bunch of listings has
pop have popped up on a ton of different
cities okay this does seem to be the
highest I did see but I saw you know
like somewhere it was like 8 to 12
percent and then this was 18 so maybe
that six percent I just chose random
cities it's not like that it proves
anything it does seem like they're a
little bit more properties being listed
than other places but it might just be
normal
no no it could also be that everyone is
leaving every single city yeah I'm not
an expert in real estate so anybody if
you guys are listening if you guys work
in real estate is this normal for 18% of
all listings to have appeared in the
past week it's 18.6 I guess seems like a
lot but but I'll add this because this
kind of adds to it
June 3rd mortgage demand from homebuyers
jumps 18% as interest rate set another
record low it sounds like they're saying
mortgage demand homebuyers because the
rates are great
June 3rd what was happening on June 3rd
what was happening on June 3rd
you don't remember have an engine third
are you kidding me dude it was a week of
riots across the country no innocent
that's a week of riots what happened
exactly on June 3rd 10 people were
running around the burning things and
throwing bricks oh and someone got a cop
oh dude this is going sure right we're
writing
I was like I was expecting some specific
thing like a meet new rat City I knew
the trap
June 3rd what what I don't I don't know
what happened specifically it was it was
you don't wait Tim you don't know what
happened June 3rd any specific events
this article came out
no no spare me yeah June 3rd we all knew
what was going on for the whole week why
would mortgage demand to be skyrocketing
at that time and CNBC is like interest
rates are a record low
oh that's why nobody's paying attention
to the to the explosions happening
outside their windows when they live in
these cities it's just a coincidence the
rates are down so they're like I'm gonna
go buy a new house somewhere else yeah
in San Francisco they're fleeing in New
York they're fleeing in Chicago they're
fleeing everybody is getting out yeah
and everybody could afford it what do
you expect man
so you're nuts gonna happen in
Minneapolis in my opinion so they said
it's a year-long plan to to abolish the
police or whatever and replace them you
know can I can you go back to that that
original article you were reading from
the yeah so the City Council unanimously
approves a resolution today declaring
the intent to create a transformative
new model of cultivating safety and
committing a year-long process of
community engagement to guide work that
should have been number one before
anything else what do you mean if the
cops can be included in that like if we
cultivate this if they do this and it's
successful like you can have police
officers and that like I set sounds
great to me I like the sound of that
reform right good idea and in fact some
of the higher profile black lives matter
activists and have been saying reform
yeah and then the extremists broke
through the dam so I look at it this way
right you have a dam that requires a
certain amount of stress before it
finally breaks and that's when you get
reformed yeah finally the dam broke but
now there's too much it's flooding the
town below instead of getting just
enough through to make positive change
humans don't do that humans are
unfortunately they go over the top yeah
so finally now we have a real
opportunity to fix things and what do
they do abolish the fund and and and in
in the Chazz they're calling for
abolishing the courts
that's insane yeah well Chad to imagine
Chad isn't the states anymore as far as
I'm concerned they're their own country
so they can have they can do away with
whatever they want to do no I have no
say of didn't we do in our country
anymore didn't someone someone say the
other day that we should put up a border
around that area and then set up
checkpoints yeah and you got to get a
passport to come in and out put some put
some CBP at the at the streets yeah they
wouldn't last and there's and there's
gonna be import and export you want to
bring into it nope yup taxes oh yes
points Jenna fixing food from from our
country oh yeah so I got I got a mention
this is though one of the funniest
things I've seen because the
libertarians are all like jumping up and
down and hooting and waving their arms
in the air because the know they are cuz
the Chief of Police said something like
the activists are going to businesses
and demanding payment in exchange to
operate in the area this is the crime of
extortion and so all the libertarians
are like did they just admit taxes or
theft going to a business and demanding
money for them to operate yeah but they
called it extortion there's there's a
difference between just just saying you
need to pay us to live here because you
were just saying to cut off their water
cut off their food cut off the the
ability to have access to all these
things that taxes help pay for so Bret
is kind of an argument for that it is a
little no no no the argument against
that is you can't cut off the water to
the residents who have nothing to do
with this
that's true a bunch of ammo so weird I
was putting put blocks in front of the
streets another people who live there
have to deal with it and yet you said it
yourself yesterday if they're not asking
for our help right if they're not asking
for help why why should we feel bad for
them no no no they're sitting in there
in there in the Chad's country I guess
in Chaz Chaz yeah the country of I don't
feel bad for him at all okay let's a lot
of these people are coming outside and
dancing and waving their arms in the air
like their post I read it where like
this is the greatest day of my life it's
the coolest thing I live here this is so
awesome
I'm letting people come hang out and
take showers they love it yeah this is
what I was saying this one uh listen
what you need to people need to
understand you can't assume they hate it
because you might hate it you know what
I mean yeah a lot of people project how
they would experience something and so
look if I lived there I'd be unhappy I'd
be like this is awful you'd be leaving
these people are crazy no I'd probably
cause trouble
I'd like course you would I would likely
know my window and I call myself King
you know King jazz or whatever I feel
I'd be like III is my property it's mine
and now I would get buddies and they
would put on like cardboard armor and
stuff true roof Korean dude yes yes yep
and then I would get I would get friends
to wear cardboard armor with cardboard
swords and stand in front of the door
cardboard swords yeah because it's silly
and I'm trying to be absurd and cause
trouble you know that's what I would do
if I was there so I gotta admit I
probably wouldn't be unhappy
I don't think Raz would would let that
happen he seems pretty uh what's he
gonna do
authoritative what's he gonna do I don't
know man mm-hmm not see if I live there
all right
I'd have my cardboard soldiers out in
front sure you would I would absolutely
would and be III it would be the
silliest stupid nonsense ever but anyway
the point is yeah I probably wouldn't be
unhappy I'd be like this is ridiculous
and silly and you know however yeah
until you needed a food and you had to
go through their checkpoints and bring
check put your food back and they go oh
okay oh no do not that foods like bars
now I'd caused so much trouble you have
no idea yeah exactly I get in you bites
yeah I know and that would lead to your
undoing you know yes and she has your
know being so optimistic it's not it's
not like you man
if I was at Occupy Wall Street okay okay
right if I lived in a building if right
now people set up on my block I would
cause an insane amount of trouble for
Occupy Wall Street is not the same as
Chaz ah come on man what's the
difference guys with guns what are they
gonna do their level they leveled up man
they level the occupy level they seemed
kind of calm I agree with that that may
be true that they're incompetent but
they're also demanding things from the
government getting things so was Occupy
Wall Street declaring it their own
country that's right that's just that's
just silliness you say that now
uh-huh you say that now you think it's
gonna grow youth yeah well according to
the the governor it's not hopefully no
now seems you don't we're know about the
situation didn't even know didn't even
know was happening in his own state and
he has the nerve to criticize Trump
trota knows what's happening in your
city and you don't and you think Trump's
doing a bad job ridiculous where's his
tweets which was so then this tweet here
there we go so let me just shout out to
Patriot zero on Twitter hit me up with
us and this is from the Seattle
government website it's basically
showing a corner in Chaz Laurita here it
says Capitol Hill autonomous zone East
pine between 10th Avenue and 12th Avenue
start date is the 7th end date is the
20th so so that supposedly there's an
end date from the governor's website why
why what is this he was aware of it what
does this mean yeah was he aware of this
yeah that's weird this is what it could
date ago this was started yeah it
couldn't just be that they have to enter
an end date okay when they database
something okay but it could also be that
they're planning on making a move yeah
and so they have a timeline mm-hmm cuz
they could have put you know nine nine
nine nine nine nine nine or whatever
instead they gave a derivative date a
definitive time I won't be surprised if
they come in and sweep everybody in the
Chazz out thanks for checking out this
clip from the Tim cast IRL podcast we do
the show live Monday through Friday at
8:00 p.m. if you want to catch the full
show tune in to this channel subscribe
hit the like button or check us out on
iTunes and Spotify and we will soon have
this podcast up for free on all podcast
platforms thanks for hanging out and
we'll see you all in the next episode
you